yeah hello and welcome to this video
this is what's happening here all right
yeah let's see what I can do against
Keyshawn yeah you see my rating tanked
quite a bit I had a bit of an unlucky
streak in the last games I lost one game
due to a connection failure yeah I
actually remembered that my internet
provided had sent me a mail that today
and tomorrow would be yeah there would
be some internet issues because they
changed some some cables or whatever and
this this happened this happened so I
lost the game by disconnection and the
other game and that was there was
unlucky I lost because of the doorbell
which had to take if you saw my
Wednesday livestream on chess 24 you
might remember that I told told the
audience that I have a problem with my
heating and simply not not I cannot
switch it off it just yeah possibly a
hot in my office and I had some some
guys over to fix that and I'm happy that
they did but they exactly they rang the
bell exactly when I was playing a game
so I lost that one okay so i wonder if
f4 is and it is something it looks
extremely dangerous for like f4 chicks
Bishop chicks takes on a 394 of course
but you can also just do this and be
better without anything anything to
calculate oh I wonder 95 to e6 it should
be a good idea
okay let's prevent age six maybe keep it
simple I get to eat six gram after the
trade that looks nice
okay I cannot take on age seven if I
play Knight is six I think I'm going to
prepare that I need f4 maybe in some
some moment to open up against the
weaknesses f4 here not quite sure it's
the most aggressive move with this this
should be good right I mean he has a
hard time now to move any of his pieces
and I'm threatening ruk f6 here with an
immediate kill I can still play rook f6
then he has to take yeah come on if
black is surviving this then something
is really that would be strange black
surviving this kind of pressure now I
play queen g6 next 94 and so on but that
cannot work yeah okay but yeah yeah
reason he hasn't moved yet no move yeah
that that looked a bit strange here for
black here I'm quite happy I've got more
space and black has very little in terms
of activity controlling this and I don't
think f5 is wrong or F forces is even
stronger here okay wow yeah that's even
stronger
because here I have this actually huh
very nice winning winning stuff so
Teague's and again f forum what did I
not see here I was thinking this either
that is just hanging up which is hanging
on everyone
yeah then of course that was strong no
here here was where I considered it huh
I was I was seeing this but I thought ok
maybe he just cancels long and I don't
have all that much which is correct
ok but this is just a good move put it
in the center how engine gives this nice
that's a nice short-term 46 at the end
ok so here and I'm just preventing h6
taking 96 ok that's there's tons of
folks so I missed a couple of quicker
and quicker wins that resolution is
really really good if I keep forgetting
this sorry position is really really
good yeah I wonder if I can I don't see
you I do I would like somehow to show
the analysis you the the the engine view
without having to switch that on and off
so that I don't forget forget it but I
don't see a technical possibility for
that here yeah and Queenie form that
that's not going to work like it's
falling apart him threatening Queen h8
stuff yeah ok guys thanks for watching